watch the Abba the apple and Peach video
he did about you
promote these blue pill people
who only focus on the [ __ ] that bro you
know what is newsworthy and what Auburn
priest should be about if their
commentary Channel who cares about Free
Speech they should have made a video
talking about the fact that I got deep
platform off of most of these social
media sites but he didn't it doesn't
matter
my man's out here right now lecturing me
talking about oh Abba if you cared you
would have talked about my Deep
platforming D platform is a big problem
Rob you out here sucking off fresh and
fit two guys who try to dmca strike and
get a bunch of channels deplatformed
right you haven't set in on a podcast
with them and had a long-form discussion
all of a sudden now that you suffering D
platforming is a big problem if you felt
so strongly you probably would have said
something but you don't because now you
need to suck off their teeth just to be
able to make some dimes
congratulations you played yourself
everybody warned you left and right that
you probably shouldn't be doing this
[ __ ] you can't swim and that you decide
to go in the deep end with the sharks
found out shit's a little steep
and all of a sudden you want everybody
to jump in there save your ass you were
warned brother
I don't think it's a good thing I don't
like seeing you being devoured but what
more can a man do like J Cole says don't
save her she don't want to be safe
that's you
today's topic sneak OSD platformed after
our last video I was contacted and
basically told like hey why would you
contact you know cover the fact that I
was on fresh and fit and not the fact
that I was de-platformed and I was like
okay and the reason why I didn't cover
the Deep platforming to be honest with
you snico is uh because I I got some bad
things to say you know
um
[Music]
there's two things that are true at the
same time one I think the issue with
deeply full ring on this platform and
others becoming more rampant is a
problem okay the fact that people cannot
even be posting stuff and be removed
from every social media like I'm not for
it okay on the other hand
snico being de-platformed was one of the
most unsurprising things of 2022. the
reason being is I was telling him this
for months I was telling him that one if
he keeps going on this way he's going to
lose everything two that he was not only
going to lose his channel sneako where
he's live streaming but the main one
where he does nothing why because
YouTube has a rule in place where if
you're acting wild or you're doing all
kinds of crazy stuff or they watch off
the platform and they decide to give you
three strikes or whatever they get rid
of everything why would it make sense
for a platform to deem the fact that you
aren't fit for their Channel their
platform that you are an issue and that
you are a problem and that lets you keep
another Channel where you get to do a
lot of the same kind of content
it's like when you get barred from a
club
and then you come back and it's like yo
you're banned from here yeah but I got a
different fit they don't care they don't
care they don't care band it's a person
so yeah it makes sense on one hand you
don't want to see the homie loses money
on the other you're doing [ __ ] that's
gonna make you lose your money you're
being warned about it multiple times
you're out here bringing out folks who
are the white supremacists folks who are
talking about race realism doing crazy
stuff your Clips are showing up in the
Senate you wild it you mean warned hey I
let my nuts hang I'm real you guys are
Bots okay well guess what you want it
you got what you wanted you're out of
The Matrix
I'm not celebrating I don't think it's
great but I think sometimes people gotta
learn their lessons you don't want to
listen nobody nobody can tell you
nothing okay this is what happens this
is what happens
some of the stuff my man was doing was
wild him talking about another female
Creator and then simulating himself
banging her okay on a platform for a
good 30 to a minute okay it's wild then
I flew to Bucharest Romania to me with
Andrew Tate and be on his podcast and
they hit me with the cyber bullying
strike for a viral video that was
uploaded two months ago if it's not
obvious anything could be labeled as
cyber bullying and anything could be
labeled as harassment he glossed over
the cyber bullying stuff but I'm like
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna show you guys
what I'm talking about you know what's
so funny about the internet
it hides the fact and like this feminist
garbage hides effect that she's
attracted to that guy making the videos
it is what it is girls you could vouch
for it you know it's true she would
she would and you know sister was so
predictable you could tell by the way
she's talking that she hasn't been
properly
in a long time it's been a while so
she's on the internet making this
garbage video promoting all the feminist
garbage to your [ __ ] lonely girls in
the comments section what you really
need Chad chat is some
um yeah shut up shut up with your
feminism yeah come here come here that's
what you need and she's gonna go
that's what you need you need some sense
[ __ ] back into you and you know what
they're gonna do right after they do
that they're gonna clip that part and
say I'm an incel problematic but you
know it's true you can hear it in their
voice she hasn't been properly and
too long and now you make no sense
that's what happens man bro this man
simulates sex like a virgin okay but
moving past that yay he did that about
another YouTuber guess what YouTube will
come down but you cannot do it on the
job in front of millions of people I
don't know what people don't understand
about this there's plenty of things I
can do at home my homies are safe with
my homies I can't do in front of y'all I
don't know what workplace you could ever
exist in where you can simulate yourself
[ __ ] one in front of customers in
front of advertisers in front of you
can't do that I tried to you didn't
really see what was that wrong with it
it's not like my man did something
innocuous or something that's like with
this no a lot of this stuff was pretty
clear-cut like yeah you're definitely
violating the rules that exist and it
pains me to say this because a young man
who if if you knew how to be smarter
about some things and wasn't so just
like I want to be real I want you look
real dumb honestly that's all it is if
you would just a bit you could have had
longevity you could have reached so many
more people had so much more influence
actually that is what Andrew said after
he got banned after he got banned said I
should have been smarter about my
messaging I should have been smarter
about this and that why because he
recognized that the way he was acting
was too wild to be viewed by this many
people extra viewership brings extra
money brings extra scrutiny or as Biggie
Smalls would say More Money More
Problems it's a conflicting thing it's
not good I'm not happy this is not a
great thing but if you're being honest
this is unsurprising and secondly you
can even make the case that it's pretty
well deserved the moment he did that
[ __ ] to that girl I was already like
YouTube's on your ass she's talking to
her YouTube manager other people are
talking to their YouTube reps they've
been tweeting at YouTube it's like bro
when you cross that line of course what
YouTuber do you think is going to get
away with themselves simulating [ __ ]
another YouTuber now if you're with the
boys at home that's one thing bruh this
is your job
guess what YouTube as cool as it is and
how everybody sees family it's a job you
got managers you got lawyers you got
agents you got middlemen you got
negotiators you got guidelines you got
guidelines you got contracts you know
we're in a workplace you can't dress a
certain way
you got guidelines and it's funny
because it made me think of a story when
I was working customer service on the
phone and there was this girl I was
complimenting about the company and the
company didn't know nothing about that
in one day the cops come and took the
girl I mean the girl Lee left the call
center in handcuffs yeah and I like the
girl the girl was great cool dude yeah
he had fun I was like what did the girl
do
and he told me while she was selling
credit cards from the calling client to
someone else and I was like
watch the Abba the apple and Peach video
he did about you
bro these blue pill people
only focus on the [ __ ] that bro you know
what is newsworthy and what Auburn
priest should be about if their
commentary Channel who cares about Free
Speech they should have made a video
talking about the fact that I got deep
platformed off of most of these social
media sites but it didn't it doesn't
matter
my man's out here right now lecturing me
talking about oh Abba if you cared you
would have talked about my d platforming
d platform is a big problem Rob you out
here sucking off fresh and fit two guys
who try to dmca strike and get a bunch
of channels the platformed right you
haven't set in on a podcast with them
and had a long form discussion all of a
sudden now that you suffering D
platforming is a big problem if you felt
so strongly you probably would have said
something but you don't because now you
need to suck off their teeth just to be
able to make some dimes
congratulations you played yourself
everybody warned you left and right that
you probably shouldn't be doing this
[ __ ] you can't swim and that you decide
to go in the deep end with the sharks
found out shit's a little steep
and all of a sudden you want everybody
to jump in there save your ass you were
warned brother
I don't think it's a good thing I don't
like seeing you being devoured but what
more can it mean do like J Cole says
don't save her she don't want to be safe
that's you
I got the logs I got the text messages I
got all the DMs I got the voice notes
you were warned dozens of times
now you want to add brand new oh this
happened to me okay well listen take
your Matrix take your red pill go off to
Bucharest suck off the Tates and just
maybe you might make a few crypto
dollars because me parsley I don't give
a [ __ ] be accountable for the actions
that you took cause literally nobody not
one person on this planet is surprised
by your downfall or you being deep
platform other than yourself
and if you had any kind of Integrity you
would go talk to the people beside you
who are in the business of engaging in
the very actions that make you suffer
today but you won't do that you won't do
that
huh
trying to get me to talk about Palestine
meanwhile you kicking it with war
criminals man get the [ __ ] up out of
here
watch the Abba the apple and Peach video
he did about you
bro these blue pill people
who only focus on the [ __ ] that bro you
know what is
no cares about Free Speech they should
have made a video talking about the fact
that I got D platformed off of most of
these social media sites but he didn't
it doesn't matter
foreign
calls and be like oh I care about you I
want you to do well I don't want you I
don't want your platform to be taken
away I just want to see you make money
okay the first stop you're already
taking the L because you're eating a
drumstick with a fork [ __ ] backwards
ass weirdo now
if you really care about what I'm
talking about you should have made a
video talking about how I got deep
platform I can't listen if I really care
about you making money I should know
I care about you keeping your career and
going well so I gave you advice to not
get the platform I find it so funny that
you get on your final video and you're
like oh man they deleted my second
Channel like you're acting surprised I
told you this was gonna happen I told
you gonna lose everything jadion told
you dancing all these people were
telling you what was gonna happen that's
how you show somebody they care not
after they [ __ ] up but before when you
warned them bro you going too fast
that's how you show somebody you care
I didn't have to tell you nothing I
could have just farmed you for views I
could have done a bunch of stuff I
really wanted to
I was warning you in private numerous
times oh I don't care okay stupid well
listen
you're playing a stupid game you'll want
a dumb price congratulations you can
carry on eating [ __ ] drumsticks with
your fork looking dumb on life I don't
care go do whatever you want to do but
don't sit here talk about
that's you stupid that's you and again
these are two videos now what have you
not heard
accountability okay all the bad things
are happening to you because the outside
world's a problem all right young man
okay well you carry on living like that
that's great while you telling these
women accountability I haven't seen you
take it a single time not once
not once but good job I actually know he
did do it once when the Muslims cocked
him into apologizing yeah yeah he had to
go religious
yeah when somebody's about to smack it
up
yeah I love tubes though stop hold on
new rule for your Chico right no rule
for you you are not allowed to make fun
of any religions on my stream until you
make fun of Islam after you do that
you're free to make fun of whatever you
want okay look at his face look at his
face
um
two hours later because I talk a lot
about wanting to convert to Islam uh
I've always talked about how the
religion that I identify with the most
is Islam
yeah no brother you gotta no no that's
it I don't have anything to joke about
islamics it's a perfect religion very
beautiful very accepting this I have
nothing to say about that nothing but
love for all religions I love all
religions equally actually I love
Judaism Christianity Islam they're all
great they're all great I I keep seeing
this meme in my head you know like those
cucked porn videos where sneakers just
sitting in the corner and there's a
Muslim man just [ __ ] his values
thank you
after nearly a decade of dedicating my
life's work to youtube.com they
terminated all of my channels for those
of you that don't know before I started
live streaming three months ago I
amassed a million subscribers on my main
Channel called sneako doing artistic
creative funny videos with the motto of
seeking truth through funny then when I
started live streaming on my second
Channel schnico I quickly grew to 850
000 subscribers in a summer they had to
do something the theme of my live
streams was labeled as red pill which a
lot of people on the internet
misconstrue as some pickup artist
misogynistic women hating when in
reality the analogy comes from the movie
The Matrix the red pill meaning the
truth since the beginning of my
streaming the Mantra I kept repeating to
my chat was that freedom of speech is
dead and if they censor it it's true and
since then they got me for three strikes
and that's why they terminated
everything not just my second Channel
but my main Channel and any fan Channel
with my name in it so I posted a YouTube
short on my main Channel saying hey guys
I can't stream for two weeks I'll see
you soon and YouTube hit me with the
circumvention strike and that's how they
were able to delete everything off the
platform it's an excuse okay you saying
it's an excuse isn't accurate
the rules in place because they don't
want you continually posting to your
audience okay you're already on play
nice they gave you the third strike okay
you already aren't they nice
you post again doesn't matter what it is
that you post they told you you can't
post it but you post elsewhere they go
comfort that is they're already watching
the feds this is why you got to do so
you want to go on Instagram you want to
go on Twitter whatever you got a left
you post it there okay there's a
difference between two things there's
what's right and what's smart is this
right you can make the case for either
or but I would probably on the fact that
I don't like people being the platform
whether I like it or hate them same
thing I said for fresh and Fit I would
say for this I don't think they should
be de-platformed however if you're
asking me what's smart this is so
incredibly stupid and a lot of the
things that you did were incredibly
[ __ ] stupid I'm telling people be
smart
that's you understanding you having the
opportunity to help folks influence
folks do whatever you want if you are
just diplomatic but folks don't want to
do diplomacy they want their way or the
highway well guess what you work for a
company
you don't want to negotiate you don't
want to be diplomatic well they're going
to tell you to take a hike because they
don't need you guys understand that like
when you're on these platforms the
reason why you want to be on YouTube is
because there's advertisers well YouTube
I didn't see them as advertisers sits
policies in place so that they can
protect their investment which is the
advertiser giving them money
you come in and you jeopardize that then
you think you don't have to negotiate
with them or give ground or anything
take a walk you work for YouTube you
work for you too they have more power at
the table listen I don't know what job
and the things that you did
in the things that you did I don't know
what job
would have given you three strikes
if you go on a normal job a normal 905
and you simulate that you're [ __ ] one
of your co-workers I don't know how
they're gonna give you three strikes
because that company is now liable
YouTube gave you the courtesy
of giving you three strikes there's no
consistency with the rules they attack
people who are going against their
agenda all the YouTubers that are
celebrating me being banned right now
have proved my point as well they are so
brainwashed and programmed that they
can't comprehend the fact that
celebrating the Banning of another
YouTuber is sick well I mean I tried to
warn him I tried to warn him and uh yeah
YouTube I mean it's YouTube's uh website
they can do whatever the fun they want
if he broke TOS then that's an L for him
but I I warned him I told him like he
was moving mad he was moving much that's
not celebrating that's not celebrating
yay he's got he's not like that that has
the tone is not yo you you said you were
moving mad I tried to warn him if he
broke the rule he broke the rule that's
not celebration bruh rough how many
people told you you were moving that
everybody was telling you're moving man
you're gonna get banned you didn't
listen anybody you let your nuts hang
you did what you wanted to do and then
you got it he's like well listen you
that's you we warned you
and you weren't moving mad
I must stop you you you you you call
that celebration this is the
hard-headedness and like the kind of
like dumb speak that you do sometimes I
I can't
you know what made me laugh too well I
was telling them hmm you know during her
discussion I was telling them like yo
listen after some time you know [ __ ]
every woman on the planet it just gets
boring like you ain't trying to get you
I remember that I remember that [ __ ]
he's like nah nah nah it's just you
getting old or whatever I said okay
whatever you don't want to listen don't
listen you like [ __ ] sneaker we all
do yeah
you like [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah
believe it or not that [ __ ] gets old
no
100 nah 100 and I could point you to you
hundreds of plays who are online right
now who have videos of them telling you
new [ __ ] gets old
in fact how about I tell you this one
and this is something even Andrew Tate
says there's something even Andrew Tate
says all right
sex becomes overrated after time no it's
overrated now
yeah he's like he says new [ __ ] like
why do you think that is
because you get used to it it becomes
like when you eat the same food over and
over again it becomes boring
that's why you get new that's why you
get new [ __ ] like you spice it up or
keep operating guess what after you've
had enough you [ __ ] there is no more
new [ __ ] there's always there's always
no fake that
at least you realize baddies ain't
nothing
so what do you why do you think why do
you think so many of these dudes as they
get older in life they stop talking
about this [ __ ] nearly as much
because they get older and they're
they're less testosterone
you don't have as much energy
dude goes to Bucharest sits in front of
Andrew Tate what do you think Andrew
Tate tells him I I don't give a [ __ ] you
can give me the baddest [ __ ] on the
planet the most beautiful girl on the
planet I don't care I don't even know
who she is but she's out there somewhere
and she could DM me on Instagram and I
can look at her and go wow you're
absolutely beautiful but if she tries to
meet me in a scenario that I think my
it's a setup or if she says something I
really don't like I'm sorry goodbye
right [ __ ] you what is this [ __ ] is sex
who cares it's a black hole Hedonism is
a black hole and there's you can go down
it forever but you'll never be satisfied
or satiated when you just go down the
black hole of Hedonism it has to be a
point where you wake up and realize no
matter how much [ __ ] I [ __ ] this hole
is going to stay as large and black as
it is now and and that's just the way
the game is and you get to a point where
you finally just say I know I can [ __ ]
girls I [ __ ] enough of them and this
is just not that funny would you play a
video game that never ended would you
like would you want to complete the
levels and complete the game if the game
just goes forever after 20 minutes
you're like this is [ __ ] this is the
game that's the game of life I just
think it's corny that you're gonna act
like oh nobody knows what they talk
about I'm gonna do whatever I want then
Tate repeats the same thing all of a
sudden you you you want to listen why is
that okay well guess what you don't want
to take the advice that's that's cool
don't take it but don't be surprised
when you lose a lot of them sympathy
points when everybody warned you you
were going too fast and then you went
smack what first head first into a walk
that's all I'm saying why do you think
someone would do that what you mean
switch like that because it's the same
information
maybe he respects taste he looks up to
date whatever it might be I don't know
but
I think if you can only take advice
based off of who says it then you're
probably not most apt when it comes to
learning I can hear good things come out
of people I even disagree with yeah
absolutely I can learn from people I
disagree but you know what what you're
saying there is true that makes sense or
maybe that's something I gotta think
about right that's what people call this
you know we're sitting on the fence and
[ __ ] like it's not a sport
where everything your team does you're
with that [ __ ] true you choose a camp
and you rock I wear those colors I
believe that and every decision that
that team makes you're like yeah even if
that doesn't make no sense you know I
mean
so yeah maybe people think oh yeah
you're just sitting on the fence but
that's not really what it is the
government is watching me the senator of
Michigan played my clip of a stream the
committee the chair of Homeland Security
said that I'm a domestic threat and that
I'm encouraging violence so that we all
understand exactly the type of extremist
content we are discussing today and I'd
like to take a moment to show a few
examples if you'd check the screen
foreign
what really happened is Susan got a
phone call from somebody on Epson Island
saying you need to get rid of this guy
he's growing too fast and he's exposing
the truth you need to get rid of him
before he keeps waking people up oh the
feds Are Gonna Get You
I'm willing just played our report
okay okay you know it's legal Brothers
up to me you know he says you bro you
afraid I'm like no
why aren't you afraid because I know
this isn't a big deal I watch the whole
thing so I watched the gold Center thing
where I showed up on the clip right I
was on Secrets podcast what ended up
happening okay
and this is the wild [ __ ] where he's
moving mad okay is I'm having a
conversation with sneakland judeon we're
just chopping it up talking about stuff
it's a good conversation right all of a
sudden snico brings on Nick Fuentes
white supremacist weirdo okay and this
man starts going off about race realism
Jewish people doing you know doing a lot
of crazy talk outlandish that clip gets
brought up before the Senate the Senate
starts posting like five six seven
videos of people saying extremist stuff
and that was like the third video out of
the seven and the reason why they
brought up that clip wasn't because I
was on screen wasn't because jadion was
on screen or because sneaker was on
screen it's because Nick Fuentes who's
banned from everything whose bank
accounts have been closed and who's like
the leader of a weird party was on
screen
so why would have you worked nothing's
happened to me nothing was going to
happen to snico but he got his own
problems there the real issue was that
you were bringing on wild people and
those people were being targeted so
that's the truth now am I nervous no not
really I don't care I don't care and
nothing's really happened and most of
the other people who were on that on
that panel nothing happened to them
but he wants to build this narrative
that the government and everybody was
coming for him and Susan and in Epstein
Island also
it's not that deep the truth is you got
banned because you were acting Wild on
the platform saying dumb [ __ ] and
simulating yourself [ __ ] another
YouTuber and that ended up being the
final cross
that's the truth but if you want to make
it a bigger conspiracy thing because it
makes you feel more important do
whatever you want I'm just not buying it
but what they don't realize is that I
don't need youtube.com to go connect
with people YouTube is just a platform
that I use what I really need is my
voice and a camera
so why you want us to cover it then well
the fact that he's saying that he
doesn't really care doesn't really need
that but I'm like why don't you talk
about me being that the platforms
yeah we're saying the same thing two
YouTubers that I looked up to when I was
a kid H3 H3 Ethan decline Ethan Klein
and KSI are both making fun of me when I
got banned even though they're YouTubers
these are two YouTubers that before I
even started YouTube I looked up to as
an example and I saw them both sell
their soul in real time after they got
canceled and after the same people that
are coming after me came after them they
sold out they gave up their principles
and they apologize they changed their
agenda and they say whatever the [ __ ] is
on Twitter trending deep down they both
know that they sold out because I know
I've been watching them for as long as
they've been making videos so when
someone like me comes around they attack
me instead of the bigger system that's
controlling us all I'm not a bad person
I'm just trying to wake you up and
they're jealous of the fact that they
should have done what I did when I find
it funny that a lot of these guys
get up on these platforms and always
preach all this stuff but never take it
for themselves
cool
you the one messed up right now you're
the one suffering all these negative
consequences but you can't see how you
played a part in all of this you don't
see the part that you played in any of
this okay I want to see these young
creators do well and a lot of them are
doing superbly well and I think it's
dope that I watch these guys grow beyond
anything I can even imagine and I want
to see them make all the money and
change their lives change their families
lives change their whole [ __ ]
lineage's life I want that for them if
they just move a bit smarter they can
avoid losing that opportunity that's it
that's it after that I have whatever I
vehemently disagreed with snico for
months and I was telling him I disagree
with like the vast majority of what
you'd be saying because I think it's
stupid but I still gave him advice to
not get a d platform why because even
though I don't see eye to eye to you I
still want to see you do well you didn't
take that advice now you say I'm not
supportive okay you know what fake
people do
fake people will sit there and tell you
oh keep going keep going even though
it's leading you to your doom that's
what fake people do I told you [ __ ] you
didn't want to hear and that [ __ ] upset
you okay well then stay
maybe you're gonna learn this lesson one
day maybe you'll never realize that
you're too hard-headed and stupid to
real I don't care that was your problem
because I can't do much more and I'm not
gonna force my advice on nobody do what
you want to do anything else oh no no
how do you feel as a beta blue pill
you would have said that a couple of
months ago a couple of years ago I'd be
like I'm not no but are you sure
who cares how do I feel platformed
hey
okay hey man okay hey it's crazy man man
gets a new platform and you realize how
badly it wants to be plugged back into
the matrix it's crazy right right you're
crazy